Thank You North VPN for sponsoring this
video yay we got a supercool deal for
you guys if your Nord VPN dot-com / JK
news you get 70% off a three-year plan
and if you use our cold JK news you get
additional four months for free nor VPN
encrypts your online activity with a
click of a button and it can make
websites think that you're connecting
from entirely different countries north
VPN is compatible with most operating
systems so you could protect both your
phone and your computer you're nodding
mother posts they have thousands of
servers in over 50 countries and you can
have six simultaneous connections but
hold on a second we got to discuss
something we were recently informed that
Noor VPN had a security breach which
isn't great but they wanted us to
address this in the ad so they can be
completely transparent with you guys us
to us too
despite this short breach no user
information was exposed so that's the
good news they wanted us to point out
that a hack is a direct attack while the
breach is just being exposed for a short
amount of time very small in response to
this nor will no longer be using any
third-party servers this will make their
service even stronger and bring up
industry standards you can read more
about the breach in a link below they
also offer 24/7 support and a risk free
30-day guarantee that's a whole month
Tommy mm-hmm go to north VPN cough /jk
news to get 70% off a three-year plan
and use the code JK news to get
additional four months for free go in
the description below for all the quick
adiy cracks and the codes and the modes
and go do the cools and the fools
thank you very much nor VPN thank you
[Music]
and back from the dead news submitted by
Jack Johnson the singer James Dean will
be resurrected with CGI to start in a
new Vietnam war movie I'm not gonna make
an Asian joke see this is why I don't
audition because like they're having
dead people play all the little roles
they're like you have no shot as an
actor that's true and animals really do
a book a lot of human parts seeing which
animals I want to talk about it my mom
was engaged to someone that owned oh my
god [ __ ] no no no no no no she has
standards there's not high justice the
mammals are I don't know Houston
everything butterflies she fries
butterflies to like you have to freeze
lady is crate and bees to yeah but I was
so pissed off because the fat cat on
Glee would always be working and then
and like that was one of her animals and
I was just like what the I was sofa
sheets Rainer whom she had like a big
she's got big ages so annoying I'm like
I'm not even getting any hoppers I'll
take it to set why is James Dean in a
Vietnam War movie because apparently
they're saying that they could not find
a better suited actor for this save what
it is what about one of the Jonas
Brothers are alike I'm all nope dead
people better yes yes this movie is it's
called finding Jack and it's set within
the Vietnam era that is based on the
existence and abandonment of more than
110 thousand military dogs at the end of
the Vietnam War and so James Dean is my
IGAs return after 60 years more than 60
years so who gets paid the James Dean
escape the estate they gave like this
movie company they were able to obtain
rights to his image when they do that
don't they isn't it like deep fakes
where like an actor is doing it and then
they're just putting his face on that's
exactly what they did with Roger Hepburn
oh oh oh when he passed away in the last
fast you've seen your audio okay would
it have been if they put James Dean a
fast and furious movie have you really
tired Oh
yeah Deanna and this is Paul Walker so
his brother his brother was able to the
other sit-in yeah Oh what the [ __ ] is
pretty close yeah codeine damn his
brother
but like the uglier version basically
nobody's man he's like oh man look at
you look at number one look at square
one
frog three seconds and a look at square
four then you're like oh [ __ ] okay yeah
this is why they that one bride that one
jakey news that we did where she was
she wanted her cousin that had like some
sort of like physical deformity wanted
to be in the bridesmaid because then I
was gonna make the bride look good this
is why no it was it in LA wedding I
don't knows on reddit anyway we're
talking about this here okay a CGI
recreation they're saying that they're
gonna completely create James Dean so
he's not gonna be the lead the lead a
character but he does have a cameo port
and role and a movie but he's just not
the lead and so they're saying that's
like now this is really telling for the
future of of moviemaking because now
they can just they can even just create
someone without even needing an actual
actor like later on down the line they
could just use CGI or or they could buy
the rights for for like let's say Will
Smith or someone else Arnold did you
guys see that
Star Wars road one movie they had Carrie
Fisher in it that looked rough well I
didn't see it but they also used that as
an example where they use CGI to create
yeah he looked fake to man it was weird
looking on I don't see the difference
you know it's gonna be funny though when
the Millennials and like everyone else
like look that doesn't know James Dean
is or was they're gonna like oh my god I
want to follow him Oh true you know like
you got played exactly yeah I mean
there's even influencers right now that
aren't real people they're like CGI Oh
like little little Michaela even CGI
they're just really not with people well
there's also that one we saw that was an
old lady do whose do
thing are you talking about like little
Michaela I think that's one of them yeah
yeah like Shane Dawson kind of exploded
her oh really
yeah because well because it's like a
CGI character and then he got obsessed
like how weird it is like so freaky
because it's like she almost looks real
but then like not yeah she does like
collabs with other people so you even
get brand deals yeah I'm like CGI or
robots which one gonna take over robots
are gonna take over I rather do CGI yeah
well context just an all-new it yeah no
genuinely I don't want to know it's not
there's a general oh just pick one Steve
I picked a real bit then I pick a real
bit rub it fine bigot planted it I'm
sure if you get one I won't even like
you I bet that it will alt fall cuz I'll
program it to Nicky will change the it's
true could it would it like you cuz like
Steve just thinks anything that that he
can't get to work just is a scam so like
the dryer doesn't even like him and
needs to be replaced because he can't
figure it out so exactly if it was a
scam now the oven when our electricity
went out the oven wasn't working because
it didn't have electricity was calling
everything a scam no it's cuz there's a
little switch and all you gotta flip to
get it to work yeah but we didn't know
if you're acting dumb like you're
pretending like you don't get it no he
legit was looking up new dryers and
gonna go buy a brand new dryer rather
just look it up there do the lunch my
man
thank you very real butter CGI oh okay
sees you got you got that how do we
don't know what it's about we just know
needs answered just have to pick one of
them that's exactly right
I picked the row bit then one to see
pick my man I know I can't won't be in
the group I say it in Twilight Zone you
know they say it rub it that's how they
say it thank you
you are correct okay it that way I am
like a robot when you said you are
correct
okay how do you sound like ICG Ivan hey
guys wow
I'm your CGI guy I'm here to help I wish
they did something about the voice c'est
la vie yeah we're in the balls version
of it so just get ready you could have
been that character with the wig on that
I had yeah that's a good voice thank you
voice kind of smells bad well [ __ ] it
probably should okay so CGI yes CGI so
they're saying that um so other people
are speculating that this company didn't
really need to do this obviously but
that they're they're creating James
Dean's image in order to really just
hype up the movie like bottom line is
just for the press are you telling me
that they're casting somebody to build
hype for a movie that sounds like
[ __ ] to me
no they're doing using CGI of a dead
person what they're casting James Dean I
just think that sounds like [ __ ]
yeah like how did he show up at his
audition it wasn't offer it was a CGI
audition offer see this is why we're
gonna not accept anything more auditions
yeah yeah so they are saying that
another actor is gonna be voicing his
lines poor guy I know
yeah that guy's gonna play until I feel
about when I see what's his what's his
name who's in who's Gollum in Lord of
the Rings they're always like we have to
take your face out every time no matter
what you do like that you know doesn't
wasn't any circus dude so use every time
you see any circus you know his face is
getting digitally replaced poor guy poor
guy poor guy yeah he's always playing
creatures and stuff always he's always
playing creatures and bad guys and all
kinds of [ __ ] he plays the monkey and
plan of the apes he played the bad guy
in the new Star Wars movie yeah just
replace him every time he's working I
was about to say that
look at eager paycheck well how much
does it suck to look at your face in the
mirror ago they would rather replace
this I think it's a good thing if he's
not ugly enough for the characters that
they need yeah that's true like yeah
your face is good enough or if you could
play the big roles that make the big
bucks but getting zero like you want to
get some bar on the street yeah I mean
he's in some of the biggest movies in
the world
yeah for sure okay water falling back to
what you said about replacing feel like
people have been doing that for
generations just not with CGI
you know horizontally what a sex robots
yeah yeah you're like replacing well no
like just in general it could be with
people give you orbits what are you how
you going so what you think do you think
one day we're all gonna wear glasses and
that all this AR [ __ ] will be just what
we see including people yeah well yeah
like if I look at you right and you
choose remember your appearance to look
a certain way no because then you could
break up with me and just have sex with
any girl because he always like I can't
I could never cheat on you because I'm
only attracted to you but then you could
just put my face on anybody even man you
put my face on Sid I put it on its head
first so I'm learning that so you know
James Dean was gay was very was he was
he was gay and he died in a car crash
for people that don't know he was he was
driving way too fast I will say yeah
wasn't me in the middle of filming or
something I think he just loved racing
he never liked the drag race and the
suicide doors or some [ __ ] like that
I think he was about to film something I
don't think he was filming something he
only did like three movies I never
understood his hype he's a little too oh
my gosh
I saw his clothes at like I forgot what
hotel it was cuz you know they had the
display I'm sure it was fake but I was
like oh my gosh have you guys ever gone
like you know I don't know where
everyone's like in in our clay when they
have a movie come out and they show like
the actual clothes that they wore in
that movie yeah they had like Ted erupts
Teddy Ruxpin clothes and I was actually
James Dean's very small very small bear
oh you
is he a real bear well yeah he was
actually James Dean's Oh like these
things called cassette tapes I don't
know I forgot I forgot you didn't have
the same childhood the rest of us huh I
didn't know - it's like yeah we all had
to tell you uh come here
[Music]
[Music]
you